well it's been a while since we've heard
from CA Harris and if you've been paying
attention to anything CA Harris has done
over the past 3 years that's not
especially surprising she has failed
spectacularly at every single task she's
been assigned since she became vice
president almost as if her whole job is
to pretend to solve problems while
actually making them worse which I guess
is basically The Unofficial job of
nearly everyone who's held a job in
Washington at any point this Century or
really for most of the century before
that as for Camila in 2021 for example
the White House put her in charge of
managing the crisis at the border but
unbelievable as it may be her strategy
of wagging her finger at Guatemalans and
telling them do not come here did not
prove to be especially effective a year
later the Biden Administration
dispatched Harris to Germany just a few
weeks before Russia invaded Ukraine with
the goal of seeking to avert a war as
the Los Angeles Times reported at the
time and in the end as we know the
Russians I guess took one look at CA
Harris and went into Ukraine immediately
with a track record like that it's not
hard to imagine that Muslims all over
the United States are quaking in fear
today and that's because this week the
Biden Administration uh gave the woman
who somehow became vice president yet
another task and this time her job was
to announce and to lead the first ever
National strategy to combat
islamophobia Harris herself made the
announcement in a video message watch
our nation was founded on the fundament
principle that all people should have
the freedom to live to worship and to be
without fear of violence or
persecution every person has the right
to live safe from violence hate and
bigotry and for those reasons and so
many more President Joe Biden and I have
a duty not only to keep the people of
our nation safe but to condemn
unequivocally and
forcefully all forms of
hate it's um always really bold always a
really bold message we
condemn hate we condemn bad things we
don't like bad things and and bad
feelings we're against them now before
we get into the whole strategy to combat
islamophobia it's important to pause uh
the video I think Ju Just to highlight
what she says in the first 30 seconds of
her big announcement she says that every
person has the right to live
safe from violence that part we can
agree then she also says live safe from
bigotry and
hate well see that part's not actually
remotely true and only someone like ca
Harris could be dumb enough to think
that it is true no you don't have the
right to live safe from bigotry and
that's because other people have the
freedom of speech and freedom of thought
and they're allowed to think less of you
for good reasons or bad reasons or smart
reasons or stupid reasons or even for
racist reasons they're allowed to they
have that right people can be as bigoted
as they want in fact as long as they're
not committing any crimes in the
process nobody has the right to be free
from the bigoted opinions and Views and
attitudes of other people that's the
whole point of the First Amendment it
protects speech that you think is good
it also protects speech that you think
is bad and as everyone says but few seem
to really believe when it comes down to
it the first amendment is really only
ever needed for that latter category if
the First Amendment
does not protect speech that people find
abhorent then the first amendment
effectively protects nothing at all but
the bid Administration apparently
disagrees and now out of nowhere they
say you have a right to be safe from
bigotry well how will the government
enforce this new right you might ask and
what exactly qualifies as
bigotry is it still acceptable to
discriminate against white males for
example if not that's bad news for
literally every corporation University
in the whole country
do they have to revise all their
policies overnight I mean is that what
we're talking
about well we already know the answer to
that question of course only certain
kinds of bigotry are forbidden the kinds
of bigotry that predominantly affect
loyal voters of the democratic party and
to that end here's command Harris
explaining the administration's plan to
combat
islamophobia and today we take another
important step forward in our fight
against hate for years Muslims in
America and those perceived to be Muslim
have endured a disproportionate number
of hate fueled attacks as a result of
the Hamas terrorist attack in Israel and
the humanitarian crisis in Gaza we have
seen an uptick in anti-palestinian
anti-arab anti-semitic and islamophobic
incidents Across America including the
brutal attack of a Palestinian American
woman who was Muslim and the killing of
her 6-year-old old son a senseless act
of violence that the Department of
Justice is investigating as a hate crime
for so many people in our nation the
past few days and weeks have brought
about all too familiar fears fears that
they will be targeted profiled or
attacked simply because of who they are
how they worship or how they look and so
today I am proud to announce the Biden
Harris Administration will develop our
nation's first national strategy to
counter
islamophobia this strategy will be a
comprehensive and detailed plan to
protect Muslims and those perceived to
be Muslim from hate bigotry and
violence now for an address that's
intended for a domestic audience it's
all very warlike our fight against hate
is underway Hara says as she sits
sternly at her little desk in front of
the American flag we have a strategy
that's comprehensive and Det detailed
she declares on social media Cal Harris
went further saying uh this action is
the latest step forward in our in our
work to combat a surge of hate in
America well hearing a sitting vice
president talk like this about American
citizens is unsettling to say the least
this is the kind of language you
normally hear our leaders use when
they're announcing a targeted strike
against terrorist cells in the Middle
East and now that language once again is
being turned inward against American
citizens the Biden Administration is on
this warlike footing against its own
citizens and and what could possibly
justify this you might ask better be
something good there better be a reason
for this kind of hostility and Brazen
disregard for the Constitution and in
particular the First Amendment but
there's no reason for this whatsoever
the only justification that CA Harris
provides in Her speech is that she says
that number one she says that that that
for years there's been a
disproportionate amount of hate being
targeted at people perceived to be
Muslim
she says that's been going on for years
and then on top of that there's
supposedly been an uptick in what she
calls islamophobic attacks in the United
States since October
7th well is that true I mean have Muslim
Americans been
disproportionally uh uh targeted for
years and has there been an
uptick Comm Harris didn't provide any
kind of
citation in fact almost every single
time that we that we hear about some
group or another that's being
disproportionately targeted in nearly
every case there's no citation offered
it's just it's just asserted it's stated
and we're supposed to accept it well
this case I went I went looking to uh
find out where this claim is coming from
and as far as I could tell the source
for this claim is the Council on
American Islamic relations or care and
there are obviously reasons to think
that care might not be the most unbiased
Source on something like this so I was
very interested to know how exactly they
determin that anti-muslim attacks are on
the rise in the United States in just
the past month well on K's website they
provide this explanation quote the
Council on American Islamic relations
the nation's largest Muslim civil rights
advocacy organization today said that it
has received 774 complaints including
reported bias incidents since the
escalation of violence in Israel and
Palestine on October
7th you know that's supposedly more
complaints than they normally receive in
similar time periods they say now to be
clear these are not reported crimes or
documented arrests much less are they
for the most part violent attacks or
anything close to that this statistic is
based on reports that somehow get
filtered to to care these are
complaints so the actual headline if you
care about being honest and accurate is
that there has been an uptick in
complaints complaints are on the rise
well are the complaints true are the
complaints complaining about actual
incidents of bigotry and what qualifies
as an incident of bigotry on that last
question we might be able to come up
with some kind of answer there have been
after all some more widely reported
incidents of alleged islamophobic
bigotry one of those reports according
to care involved quote a man who
reportedly drove his truck through a
through and brandished weapons against
pro- Palestine protesters in
Minnesota well that sounds pretty bad it
sounds hateful even so I looked into
that incident a little bit more and
here's the video of what happened which
K actually provides the link to and um
here's what happens
[Applause]
watch maybe come on
I'm right
here I
know so that changes things a little bit
for one thing there was no truck
involved in this incident it's clearly a
sedan what looks like a Ford Fusion uh
you know just semantics but if we care
about being accurate and it's obvious
from the footage that the mob of
so-called Pro Palestine protesters were
blocking the street they were standing
in the middle of the intersection just
blocking off the intersection which they
have no authority to do I know that
leftist protesters do this all the time
and I guess I don't know if people
assume that they have legal authority to
do it they don't actually turns out that
just because you have some uh cause that
you care about that doesn't give you the
authority to just shut down traffic
whenever you feel like
it and so the man attempts to uh
continue on his way the mob surrounds
the car starts banging on the windshield
kicking the car and going
crazy and by the way at this point
they've surrounded the entire car so
that no matter where the guy goes he's
going to be running into protesters
right if you don't want to be run into
don't surround every every Escape uh
route is there are people around it
there's nowhere he can
go what is he supposed to do just offer
himself up to the Mob to be Torn to
Pieces
now even if you think the driver was in
the wrong somehow which he wasn't um
there's also no indication that he hates
Muslims if anything he he seems to hate
protesters who block traffic and that is
a form of bigotry that nearly everyone
can relate to now according to a blogger
who was on the scene one protester
complained quote it was scary honestly
because there have been protests where
people run through the crowd with their
vehicles and people like ended up dying
and then knowing he was armed like a
part of me wanted to run away but a part
of me was like trying to assist everyone
else in like stopping this car from
causing more harm too because there's
children here there's families
here um well here's an
idea uh maybe don't take your children
to the middle of the road and block
traffic okay maybe don't stand in an
intersection with your
children but that concept is Unthinkable
to these protesters apparently and in
their effort to sell this incident as
islamophobic various left-wing activists
uploaded uh additional footage and in
this one we we can see the man
brandishing a knife after he was
surrounded let's watch
[Music]
that okay so they're making this guy out
to be some kind of white supremacist
some kind of islamophobic terrorist
because he was driving in his car a mob
surrounded him and he brandished a knife
to defend def himself and he quickly
realized that a knife against this whole
crowd this whole mob is not going to do
much good he gets back into the car
didn't actually hurt anyone and this is
the kind of incident that care is
classifying as
islamophobic when there is no evidence
at all that this guy has any Muslim
anti-muslim bigotry
period and in turn the White House is
using incidents like this to claim that
Muslims are seeing some kind of
heightened backlash which justifies
wartime foing against Maga Republicans
in all forms of quote unquote hatred
they're also using incidents it would
appear that are far more ambiguous and
irrelevant than this keep in mind that
again reports mere reports of biased
incidents are being counted in the
total well what is a biased incident
there is no one single definition and
that's the point really you know it's
it's just something it can be whatever
they want it to be but every University
in the country has its own bias incident
response team and if you go to any
University website and you find their
bias incident page you'll see some kind
of definition that they're all very and
all the definitions are very similar and
so generally when anyone on the left
talks about bias incidents this is what
they're talking about here's the
University of Denver for for example
This Is How They Define it the
university defines bias incidents as any
behavior that targets uh individuals or
groups based on their actual or
perceived group identities examples may
include but are not limited to Graffiti
harassment jokes direct insults Etc the
specific forms content motivation and
tension and impact of bias incidents
vary jokes are included so a bias
incident is anything that someone says
or does that someone else
interprets as biased which is to say
that an increase in biased incident
reports really doesn't mean anything at
all and and if you announce ahead of
time that a a certain group is going to
start experiencing more biased incidents
and then members of that group
immediately start complaining about
biased
incidents that does not indicate that
there are actually more biased incidents
whatever a biased incident even is all
it indicates is that the people in that
group are being encouraged to interpret
incidents that
way so why exactly is the B
Administration doing this the most
benign possible explanation is that
they're not planning on really doing
anything like this is not anything it's
theater and they're just trying to win
some votes in swing States like Michigan
by pandering to various Muslim
communities by announcing a national
strategy to combat Islam islamophobia
and if that's true it wouldn't be the
first time that the White House has done
something like this in fact just a few
months ago the White House announced its
bold New National plan to combat
anti-Semitism they pledged that it would
end hatred against Jews in the United
States but if you've been you know
seeing any of the footage from college
campuses recently you know that the
White House's plan hasn't exactly
accomplished much it was all PR so maybe
the same thing is happening here with
this new plan to combat
islamophobia uh maybe they're just going
to record a video and release a press
release and just move on but there's
reason to think that something else is
going on here you might have noticed
that over the last few years uh the left
and the media tend to announce ahead of
time that there will be a rise of a
certain kind of hate crime according to
current events and then like magic the
prophecy curiously tends to fulfill
itself and then the left uses that
increase in hate to assume more power
and to demonize their political
opponents we saw this uh during coid
nearly as soon as Co made its way to the
United States Democrats if you remember
started declaring that the worst thing
about the virus is how it would lead to
anti-asian sentiment and they started
saying this right away and then what do
you know that uptick happened right on
schedule as ABC News reported in 2021
quote a new study suggests that former
president Donald Trump's inflammatory
rhetoric around the Corona virus which
is believed to have originated in China
helped spark anti-asian Twitter content
and likely perpetuated racist
attitudes at the same time Democrats
refused to acknowledge the obvious fact
that the so-called hate crime surge
against Asians during coid was almost
entirely driven by black perpetrators
which is a demographic group that votes
Democrat or a demographic Group which
votes Democrat by a margin of 9 to1 as
City Journal reported quote blacks are
responsible for 305% more violent crime
against Asians than neighborhood
demographics would predict while whites
and Hispanics commit significantly fewer
attacks against Asians than would be
expected now Democrats never talked
about those numbers because they didn't
want to demonize one of their primary
voting blocks they constructed a
narrative and they followed through with
it no matter how obviously false it was
that's how cynical these people are
they're also profoundly unoriginal which
is why we're now seeing the same
strategy play out all over again in
exactly the same way they're desperately
hoping that their whole narrative about
quote unquote islamophobia will manifest
in reality if they just keep pushing it
over and over again and either way
they'll pretend it has manifested
whether it really has or not but the key
point is that even if you concede the
left Central claim even if you pretend
it's true that we're seeing a rise in
attacks on Muslims in this country then
there's still no justification for the
federal government to announce a plan to
police hate because whether it's hate
against Muslims or Jews or white people
or anyone else hate itself on its own is
not something the Biden Administration
has any Authority or any ability to
resolve hatred is an emotional state it
exists in the human heart you cannot
eliminate it even if you
tried which is of course good news for
Liberal activists the very people who
are pushing this Federal war on hate
because they're among the most hateful
people on the planet they're gleeful
whenever any of their political
opponents lose their jobs or even their
lives so if anyone should be jailed
under some Grand new who plan to punish
hateful people then it's them but you
can't do that you can't police
hate now if somebody commits an actual
crime driven by hate you can punish the
crime but then the fact that it was
motivated by hate as opposed to some
other nasty emotion is basically
irrelevant or it should be hate itself
the emotion the thought is outside the
purview of the government when the White
House announces yet another war on hate
it's actually announcing a war on
feelings that it thinks we shouldn't
feel
the vice president is saying there are a
lot of people feeling unapproved
emotions and we're going to put a stop
to that and when you think of it that
way which is the accurate way you see
how dystopian this really is it's also
again
impossible they cannot stop hate even if
we agree that they should try and and we
do not
agree but they can use the pretense of a
war on hate to seize more control over
our lives and they hope our minds
and of course that's what all this is
really
about thanks for checking out this video
if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts